we need to factor negative 12x squared
minus 30 8f plus 22 so a good place to
start is to see if is there any common
factor for all three of these terms when
you look at them they're all even and we
don't like a negative number out here so
let's divide everything or let's factor
out a negative two so this expression
right here is the same thing as negative
two negative two times what's negative
12x squared divided by negative two it's
positive 6f squared negative 38 divided
by negative 2 is positive 19 so it'll be
positive 19 F and then 22 divided by
negative 22
sorry join 2 divided by negative 2 is
negative 11 negative 11 so we've
simplified it a bit we have the 6f
squared plus 19 F minus 11 we'll just
focus on that part right now and the
best way to factor this thing since we
don't have a 1 here is the coefficient
on the F squared is to factor it by
grouping so we need to look for two
numbers whose products is 6 times
negative 11 so two numbers so a times B
needs to be equal to 6 times negative 11
or negative 66 and a plus B needs to be
equal to 19 a plus B needs to be equal
to 19 so let's try a few numbers here so
let's see 22 22 I'm just thinking of
numbers that are roughly 19 apart
because our going to be of different
signs so 22 and three I think will work
right if we take 22 times negative 3
that is negative 66 and 22 plus negative
3 is equal to 19 and the way I kind of
got pretty close to this number as well
you know they're going to be a different
signs so the positive versions of them
have to be about 19 apart and that
worked out 22 and negative 3 so now
let's we can we can rewrite this 19 F
right here as the sum of the sum of two
of negative 3 F and 22 F so it's
negative 3 F plus 22 F that's the same
thing as 19 F I just kind of broke
apart and of course we have the six F
squared and we have the minus eleven
here now you're probably saying hey Sal
why did you put the 22 here in the
negative three there why didn't you do
it the other way around when you put the
22 and then the negative three there and
my main motivation for doing it I like
to put the negative three on the same
side with the six because they have the
common factor of the three I like to put
the 22 with the negative eleven they
have the same cop factor of 11 so that's
why I decided to do it that way so now
let's do the grouping and of course you
can't forget this negative two that we
have sitting out here the whole time so
let me put that negative two out there
but that'll just kind of hang out for
awhile let's do some grouping so let's
group these first two and then we're
going to group and then we're going to
group this let me get a nice color here
and then we're going to group this
second two that's almost an identical
color let me do it in this purple color
and then we can group that second two
right there so these first two we could
factor out a negative 3f so it's
negative 3f times 6x squared divided by
negative 3f is negative two F negative
2f and the negative 3f divided by
negative 3f is just positive F actually
a better way to start instead of
factoring out a negative 3f let's just
factor on 3f so we don't have a negative
out here
we could do it either way but if we just
factor out a three f6f squared divided
by 3 F is 2f and then negative 3f
divided by 3 F is negative one so that's
what that factors into and then that
second part in that dark purple color we
can factor out an 11 so we get factor
out an 11 and if we factor that out 22 F
divided by 11 is 2 F and negative 11
divided by 11 is negative 1 and of
course once again you have that negative
2 hanging out there you have that
negative 2 now inside the parenthesis
inside the parenthesis we have two terms
both of which have 2f minus 1 both of
which have 2f minus 1 as a factor so we
can factor that out this whole thing is
just an exercise and in doing the
reverse distributive
property if you will so let's factor
that out so you have to F minus one
times this 3f times that 3f and then
times that plus eleven times at plus
eleven let me do that in the same shade
of a lot of that same shade of eleven
same shade of purple right over there
and if you you know you can distribute
if you like to F minus one times three F
will give you this term 2f minus one
times eleven will give you that term and
we can't forget that we still have that
negative two hanging out outside I want
to change the colors on it we have the
negative two hanging out that same
negative two over there and we're done
factoring it negative 12x squared minus
38 F plus 22 is negative 2 times 2 F
minus 1 times 3 F plus 11